Okay, we're black against Yuri Nkemetianov, that is quite a handful, a mouthful of a name.
And let's see if we finally get another main line Accelerated Dragon, not size 6, and C3.
So again, we're facing the Alepin, and this is very interesting, we're facing a version
of the Alepin that does not allow us to play the line that I recommended.
So the line that I recommended has a bit of a flaw.
You might remember that in response to the standard Alepin, I recommended D5, E takes
D5, and then Knight F6.
Obviously with the Knight already on C6, if we play D5, then we kind of have to recapture
with the Queen.
So it's just that this particular version of the Alepin is rare, most people play it
straight away.
So here we're going to have to play a different line, we're going to have to play either Knight
F6, E5, Knight to D5, or we're going to have to play D5 and get into that main line.
Or we can play the move E5, which I know is a very interesting sideline, it's gained in
popularity recently, but the only downside is that I don't know it very well.
In terms of my own knowledge, I know Knight F6 a lot better than the move E5, and E5 white
is better with best play, but it can be very hard to prove it if you're not super well-versed
in Alepin theory.
Let's risk it.
Let's see what happens.
Let's go E5.
I'm just interested in my ability to improvise.
Let's see if we can outfox our opponent in territory that will hopefully be new to both
of us.
So E5 is a very risky move conceptually for two reasons.
First of all, and mainly, it creates a big hole on D5, but in many Sicilian lines, we
like to arrange our pawns on C5 and E5.
The hole on D5 is really not the end of the universe because that square can be pretty
effectively protected by a bunch of the minor pieces.
In the Nidorf, by the way, you also see black play E5 and weaken that square and live to
tell the tale.
D4 is one of white's two main moves.
The other one is Bishop F1 to C4, kind of playing this Italian style.
Here white strikes at the center.
This is the main line, and this leads by force to a kind of mass trade in the center.
We could play D6 here, but that affords white the option of forcing an endgame that's really
undesirable for black.
So we kind of have no choice.
We play Cd, Cd, we play Ed.
This is the theory that I know.
And what I would compare this position to is a scotch, the only difference being that
the C pawns are gone.
We literally have a scotch opening like E4, E5, Knight F3, Knight C6, D4, Ed, Knight D4
with the C pawns absent.
No question that that favors white a little bit, and the reason that favors white is because
this D6 square is now quite a bit tender.
So if we were to play Bishop to C5, which by the way is what I like to play against
the standard scotch, white has the additional move Knight to F5, and it appears to me that
the weakness of the D6 square might justify that line for white.
We might still have to play it, but there is a move which I like quite a bit more, which
is Knight to F6.
I think Knight F6 doesn't have the same problem.
White has no time to play Knight F5 here because the E4 pawn is hanging.
So we get kind of a scotch, a slightly worse version for black, but this is very much playable
I think.
Knight C3.
Okay, so now in the main line for Knight scotch, which we've kind of transposed to, black's
main move is Bishop to B4.
I think this move makes a lot of sense here as well because we're trying to put pressure
on the E4 pawn.
There's also a very interesting move, Knight takes E4, which I'll talk a little bit about
after the game, but I don't want to risk it, and I think we should play straightforward
chess here.
Let's start with Bishop B4, and then we'll check the theory after the game.
Yeah, white has to prove the advantage here because we're treating this like a four-knight
scotch, which incidentally is my recommendation for white.
And if we were to add the C pawns, white's main move is Knight takes Knight, pawn takes
Knight, and then the Bishop from F1 comes out typically in this line to D3 in order
to support the E4 pawn because the pawn needs another supporter.
We're threatening Knight takes E4.
That's why we bring our Bishop out specifically to B4 in this line.
Note that white can't play Bishop D3 immediately because that would drop the Knight on D4.
Very common blunder, people forget to take the Knight first.
And I think our opponent is finally on his own.
We've done a good job of improvising, I think.
Bishop to G5.
Ooh, this looks very dubious to me.
I just, when I see this move, it's hard for me to verbalize it right off the bat, but
there's just something about this move which looks unsustainable to me.
And what it really is, is the fact that the Bishop on G5 is undefended, and the fact that
white's not really addressing the pin against the Knight.
These types of indirect defensive moves are always very risky for many reasons.
So one thing that we could do, I think the most straightforward way to treat this position
with black is to play the move H6 and chase the Bishop away.
The point is, if white drops back to H4, then we can play G5.
Force the Bishop to G3, and then we play Knight takes C4, and we win the pawn.
If after H6, white takes the Knight, then we take back with the Queen.
Not only do we attack the D4 Knight, but we bag the Bishop pair, which is a great thing
in a wide open position.
But there is another move that my attention is drawn to, and that's Queen D8 to A5.
And you get this type of Queen sortie pretty often.
You wouldn't get it, by the way, with the addition of the pawn on C7.
So that's an additional resource that we get, because there's no pawn on C7.
Didn't think it would be a good thing.
What does Queen A5 do?
Well, Queen A5 is just a double attack.
It hits the Bishop, and we're threatening Bishop takes Knight check.
And that's a problematic situation for white, because white doesn't have time to come back
to D2 with his Bishop.
Then white drops the Knight on D4.
So after Queen A5, white might have to play Knight takes C6.
In that position, we could take the Knight with check, but I don't love that option.
So probably we would take the Knight back with Bc, and then white could wiggle out by
dropping the Bishop back to D2.
Not a great position for white, but it's not like winning for black either.
I think we'll play it simple, and we'll go with H6.
Let's see what our opponent has cooked up here.
I'm just curious, because H6 is like the in-your-face move.
Yeah, our opponent gives away the Bishop there.
Already a very nice position for black.
Nine moves in.
And problems for white concretely, because he's just not developed, and the King is stuck
in the center.
So white has to tread very carefully to avoid further material losses, and you could lose
this game in like three moves easily.
Knight to B5.
So I'll put it this way.
In this position, there is an adventurous move that sadly doesn't work.
It almost works, but it doesn't.
So what do I see when I look at this position?
Well, the first thing I notice is that if we would remove this Knight from B5, we would
have Bishop takes Knight check, and then Queen takes Pawn check, and that's awesome, because
white can essentially never block with Queen d2, because the Rook on a1 hangs.
We can force white's King to e2.
That's a huge thing.
So the move A6 comes to mind.
A lot of people would reject A6 because of Knight c7 check, but in and of itself, the
fork is not dangerous.
Knight c7 check, King d8.
And if white plays Knight takes a8, then we play Bishop takes c3 check.
We recapture with the Queen, and if the King goes up to e2, we can actually win white's
Queen by giving a check on d4 with the Knight.
Knight d4 check.
The King on e2 is checkmated, so white has to give up the Queen for the Knight.
Here's the problem.
This is hard to see.
After A6, Knight c7 check, King to d8.
Who can tell me what white's best move is in that position?
Not easy at all, because your eyes are fixated on the Rook in the corner.
It's hard to come up with this move.
Knight back to d5.
Yeah, Knight c7 back to d5.
That hits the Queen.
It centralizes the Knight, but mainly it defends the Knight on c3.
So A6 actually is a mistake.
If A6 is a mistake, that basically means we have only one feasible move other than A6,
which is to castle, is to get the King out of the center.
Now A6 becomes a huge threat, because Knight c7 is no longer a check, and we would be able
to take the Knight in the corner.
So here we have another dilemma.
A3 has been played.
The default move to me is Bishop a5.
The other move is Bishop to c5, because it threatens mate on f2.
But I like Bishop to a5, because we're inducing the move b4.
Why is b4 something that's good for us?
Well, because b4 makes the Knight on c3 even weaker.
It also opens up an X-ray between the Black Queen and the White Rook on a1, which means
that any time white plays Knight to d5 in the future, chances are there might be a tactic
connected to white's Rook in the corner.
Bishop a5 is good from all sides.
It keeps the pin on the Knight.
It keeps the threat of a6.
And if we can force white to play the move b4, then we've created even more weaknesses
on the Queen side.
So we play this move really without additional calculation.
We just use comparison to determine that a5 is the best square for the Bishop.
Yeah, after b4, a lot of you are noticing Knight takes b4.
I'm not sure we want to sack the Knight there.
I don't think that was a good idea.
We'll talk about it after the game.
Okay, so we can take this game in a lot of different directions.
This is a pretty exciting position.
We have a lot of tactical potential in our position.
So I would divide moves in this position into like a simple category, and then more tactically
oriented moves that have to be calculated.
There is a move here that I'm drawn to, which is highly tactical.
It's the move d7, d5, sacrificing the pawn in order to quickly open up the rest of our
pieces.
So d5 is a move that we come up with intuitively, but there are also simpler moves.
a6 is tempting, but probably White is going to stick the Knight on d6 as a response, okay?
And what was the point of Rook c1?
It was to reinforce the Knight on c3.
It was a great move.
So after a6, Knight d6, we could play a move like Knight c6 to d4.
Probably we're going to trade on c8, and Black is maybe a little bit better.
Is there anything with more meat on the bone?
Well, it's hard to say.
The move Rook to e8 also came to my mind.
It's on my radar because it hits the pawn on e4.
Rook takes e4, it becomes a threat because the Knight on c3 is spanned.
So Rook e8 is another good move.
I like a6.
I think a6 might be the simplest approach to this position.
d5, I'm not sure there's a follow-up after e takes d5.
It's tempting then to deliver a check, but White blocks the check with Bishop e2, and
White is ready to castle in the resulting position.
Once White castles, that's it.
Our attack in the center evaporates.
d5 is a little too crazy.
We'll explore it a little bit more after the game.
But I really like the look of Rook e8.
I like the look of Rook e8 because we're also tempting White into playing what I think would
be a serious mistake, Bishop to d3.
This is like such a common move at all levels because it's a reactive move, and what people
forget to do is when we discuss a developing move, people forget to check the drawbacks
of such a move.
And boy, could it have some drawbacks.
b4 is what our opponent plays.
Without further ado, let's drop our Bishop back to b6.
The sack on b4 would be bad because even after we take on b4, congrats, you still have the
pin on the knight, but you're not threatening the knight on c3.
So White has that tempo that he could use to play Queen d4.
Maybe it would have been interesting, but that's not the kind of chess that we're trying
to play in the speedrun.
We're trying to play, first and foremost, our allegiance is to fundamentally sound chess.
So if we allow White to castle here, this is what makes this such an exciting position,
if White could play Bishop e2 and castles kingside, from a positional standpoint, we
are worse, and largely the absence of the c7 pawn, you can see how it makes us pay positionally.
Look at these weak squares, d6 and d5.
These are outposts for both of White's knights.
So we can't allow White to consolidate and start occupying these outposts.
We need to keep pounding at him while he hasn't castled yet.
So Rook to c2, all right.
So this is really interesting.
We have a lot of promising moves.
I don't think Rook c2 was a particularly good move.
So a6 again, he wants Knight d6, and then some of you might see Bishop takes f2 check.
Okay, that's a tactic.
Rook f2, Queen f6 takes c3 check.
White will probably block with the Queen, and we get an endgame up a pawn.
Okay, that's an option, but I don't like allowing the Knight onto d6.
What else do we have?
Well, we can still play the move d5, which I'm really attracted to because Knight takes
d5 doesn't work.
We take on e4 with check, and then we can actually take on f2 on the next move.
And what I also like about the move d5 is that the e-pawn is now pinned.
So if White wants to take the pawn, he has to take it with his Queen, and that then allows
us to develop with tempo.
I'm going to make this move essentially on the basis of intuition alone, because this
is what people don't really understand about pawn sacrifices.
It's not such a big investment.
Even if White collects the pawn, which he can only do with a Queen, and magically consolidates.
White develops the Bishop and castles with a wide open center.
You know for a fact that you're going to have great compensation, even if White castles.
So it's not such a big risk to give up a pawn in a middle game.
Most games are decided by a much bigger margin than an extra pawn.
At a GM level, yes.
But at the level of the people who are watching, you know, sack pawns.
If you think it's good, if you think it gives you peace activity, you should err on the
side of taking the risk.
The threshold I think is a minor piece.
If you're sacking a minor piece, that is the tendency to, that is the potential to decide
the game if it doesn't work out.
So you generally need to calculate much more concretely than when you sack a pawn.
Yeah, people of that sort, you know, weak players.
And Daniel, Daniel condescending as usual.
And again, I don't, I, in all seriousness, I obviously don't mean this condescendingly.
I just mean this realistically, right?
You know, not everything is the same at all levels in chess.
And you know, you have to tailor your play to where you're at.
Okay, Bishop to d3.
Our opponent desperately trying to defend the e4 pawn.
But this is a lost cause.
Because as long as we keep the pin on the e-file, d takes e4 is begging to be played.
Because after white recaptures, the knight or the bishop, you just get into the frying
pan.
There must be something in that resulting position.
There must be.
Now, a6 here traps the knight on b5.
But notice that white has knight takes d5 as a result.
And even in that position, we can play queen g5 and g2 is hanging, but that gets messy.
Let's start by taking on e4.
Then we need to invest some time and see if we can figure out a winning move after knight
takes e4.
Because white is now one move away from castling, which means that we need to strike now or
forever hold our peace.
Okay, let's think.
Let me think about this for a second.
There are several like interesting moves.
I'm just trying to find the best one.
Okay, I think I found it.
I think I figured out what to do.
And I think the simplest move is the best one here.
Yeah, bishop f5.
It's what everybody's suggesting.
But this is not an automatic move, and I'll explain why.
It took me a second to refute rook e2.
Rook e2 fails to a very pretty tactic.
You should notice right off the bat that the f2 square is a problem square for white.
I don't care that there's a pawn there.
So after rook e2, we just play bishop takes, bishop takes, rook takes, deflection, rook
takes, queen takes, f2 mate.
That means white basically has to play pawn f3.
And the great thing about inducing pawn f3 is that white can no longer castle because
the bishop on b6 is controlling g1.
So then we can finally breathe a little bit easier, and we can play quote unquote slow
moves to accumulate the pressure.
We don't even have to think in that case about going directly for the kill, although we should
look for winning tactics if they exist.
So what would be an example of a quote unquote slow move that we could play after f3?
What's a move that just sort of like improves our position and creates more potential long-term
threats?
Yeah, just rook a to d8, which should be automatic too.
I've talked about this often.
Moves like rook a to d8 are incredibly powerful if you have the time to play them.
How do we know we have the time to play them?
Well, we know that after f3, white is no longer close to castling.
You understand the logic should make sense.
Now rook a to d8 is far from the only move.
You can play a6 there and chase the knight away and then stick your own knight on d4.
Maybe you're attracted to that possibility, but I like keeping this knight on b5 because
it's super vulnerable, and we can play a6 whenever we want to play it, and it would
be winning.
Knight c3, okay.
Probably the best move.
So what I'm seeing is queen to g6.
That's one option.
White castles and then we take a bunch of times on e4 and we have two pieces for a rook,
which by the way, the last speedrun game featured two pieces for a rook.
I'd like to avoid that if possible.
There is a move that I like a lot more.
There's a move that I like a lot more than queen g6, which actually is rook a to d8,
and the idea is to pin the queen, and some people might refute this move because you
allow white to castle, but even after white castles, we play bishop takes e4, knight takes
e4, and of course the idea is to play rook takes e4.
Bishop e4, rook takes queen, rook takes rook.
Black has a queen and a knight for two rooks, which is an overwhelming amount of material.
If you're newer to chess, queen versus two rooks is approximately equal material.
If you have another minor piece on top of it, you're chilling.
You're totally good.
You're totally chilling.
So we're just accumulating, right?
Rook a to d8, which is a move we know is good, and if white plays rook e2, we have a beautiful
tactic.
Let's see if he falls for it.
I mean, maybe the tactic doesn't work.
No, he castles.
Okay, so we're going to win this in rather unglamorous style, but still.
I think a game that illustrates just how disastrous it could be to keep your king in the center
for too long.
And then once and for all, okay, so rook takes e4.
That's why we put the rook on d8.
We were basically playing against black white's queen and against white's king at the same
time.
That's why we put the rooks on the two open files.
White has to take.
At this point, white has to give it a shot.
But then we take.
White takes.
We'll make a little bit of loft with a move like g6 so that there's no back rank shenanigans.
And then the game should be a matter of converting a big material advantage.
This is game over.
It all looks very simple when you play a game like this, but you could see that a lot of
thought actually went into a lot of the moves in the middle game.
Okay, b5.
Okay, there's a thousand ways to play here.
The method we want to choose is one that eliminates complexity and is very simple.
So what I mean by that is the rook on e4 is still a hanging piece.
If possible, we'd like to avoid moves that exacerbate the complexity.
Is there a way to move this rook away from the vulnerable square?
There is the move, knight e5.
Knight e5 is a great move.
Bishop e4, rook d1.
But there's another great move, which is even simpler, which is to play rook e4 to d4.
Rook ed4, right?
We're counterattacking the bishop.
There's an important line there, actually.
So let's play rook ed4, bc, rook takes d3.
White can play the move c7.
That can look scary, but we can just take white's queen because if white takes our rook
and makes a new queen, we have three pieces that can recapture on d8.
The rook d4 is simple, bc, rook takes d3.
You solidify the extra piece.
And then on the next move, you can play b takes c6.
There's actually a crazy idea that white has here, which I didn't see.
And the idea is queen takes d3.
Rook takes d3, and c takes b7, and white is threatening to promote the pawn.
And white has this move, rook to c8, to assist in the pawn's promotion.
But black has several ways to win in that position, I'm pretty sure.
We'll cross that bridge when we get there.
Actually, that's a very, very problematic idea.
Very problematic idea.
No, we have a beautiful win there, actually.
I really am hoping he plays it, because we have a beautiful winning idea in that position.
Beautiful.
Come on, I actually really hope he plays it.
This is one of the cases where I'm hoping that he makes the quote-unquote best move.
How do you see a move like queen takes d3?
Well, it's the rule.
Anytime there's a pass pawn on the 6th rank, or on the 7th rank, in the middle game, and
game doesn't matter, you have to look at tactics that basically involve, what do they involve?
Clearing the way for, clearing the way for the pawn.
We're going to likely have the same tactic after our opponent plays rook takes d6.
The same tactic that we would have used to win the game after queen takes d3, we have
now.
Can anybody see it?
This is a classic puzzle rush pattern.
Everybody should know this pattern.
This happens in puzzle rush all the time.
Queen takes f2.
Unfortunately, it's not made.
White can play king h1 here, technically, but the point, of course, is rook after rook
d1 is made.
Queen takes d1, rook d1 is made, because the rook is automatically pinned when it captures
the queen.
What you need for this kind of tactic is access to the back rank, and then a queen-bishop
battery against the f-pawn.
You play to deflect the rook, and the rook occupies the role of a third pawn on f2.
It's pinned, so it's like a pawn.
This is nice, but okay.
Now we can continue the pretty play.
We can simplify into an endgame.
This is another pattern that you should all be familiar with.
Anytime you have access to the back rank, you have access also to simplifying combinations.
Tactics that are not aimed at checkmating your opponent, but are aimed at forcing a
bunch of trades.
No, don't play rook d1 here, because white has two defenders on that square.
First, well, queen e2 is the move I would play in a clash.
Actually, queen e2 might be winning on the spot, let me think.
Yeah, yeah, I'm going to amend, yeah, but queen e2, white has rook, queen e1.
What I'm talking about is queen take, let's play this move, just to illustrate the concept.
Queen takes f1, very simple.
White takes back, and then you re-pin the queen with rook to d1.
You re-pin the queen with rook to d1, and incidentally, this is almost checkmate.
Like white can't take.
White does have the move, technically, rook to c1.
Okay, but the game is over, we're up a freaking piece.
So the simplest way, there's two main ways to win a position like this.
The first is to trade rooks, and trading rooks will leave us with only a bishop, that'll
make it really easy.
The second way is just to go after white's remaining pawns, and the pawn that you should
really try to go after is a3.
And then combining the two ideas often yields very quick victories.
So the first move, okay, would be rook d3.
White would have to choose between a4 and rook a1.
If a4, then rook a3 picks up the pawn.
If rook a1, then you dislodge the rook with bishop d4, you win the pawn, and then incidentally,
white can't stop the move rook a1, which would trade rooks, okay?
So no rematch.
Let's have a look at, first and foremost, the opening theory.
But before we do that, I want to mention, in the end, what would have happened after
queen d3, rook d3, cb.
So there's multiple ways to win here.
There's multiple ways to win, but the prettiest is this move, queen f4, which is a move that
you should see.
I mean, that stops the pawn, but it also looks like it doesn't work because, of course, white
has this check.
And after king h7, white promotes.
But if you're familiar with the tactic, here, black has queen f2.
And in contrast to the game continuation, the rook on f1 is undefended, so king h1 is
futile.
Rook f2, rook d1 is also checkmate.
But there's a twist.
In this position, white has an attempt to improve on this line.
Rather than playing rook c8 immediately, white can throw in the intermezzo g3.
Now, what does g3 do?
Well, what g3 does is it eliminates the mechanism, right?
If the queen stays on this diagonal after rook c8, black is still winning with rook
d8, by the way.
But now, you don't have this queen takes f2 combination.
But rather than playing queen e5, black has another beautiful idea, which is another idea
that you should be familiar with when you're pinning the f-pawn.
It's rook takes g3, the rook, yes.
Hg3, queen g3, using the pin on the f-pawn, the poor f-pawn.
And now, you use the exposed nature of the king to simply pick up the pawn that's the
easiest way to win, and you're overwhelmingly up material.
So, some very, very nice details here.
That would have been the best way to win.
Incidentally, you can also start with rook d8.
You can also do this, and you can also win like this, king h7.
This is also winning because, again, if white promotes, then queen takes f2 as mate.
If white takes the rook, then you take back, and here it's easy to surround and win the
pawn.
And if white plays some move like g3 in order to try to prevent queen takes f2, then believe
it or not, the engine move is rook d2.
This is like typical engine play because the engine allows you to promote because it's
calculated until checkmate.
Humans don't play like that.
Here, king h1, queen f3 is mate, and if the king steps into the line of fire of the rook,
then you just drop the bishop back, force the king out, you take on f1, and this is
obviously going to be checkmate in just a couple moves.
Yeah, no, very, very complicated lines actually, but let's rewind.
Let's start from the start because we faced this line.
We decided to play e5.
I'm going to check what the Aleppine Bible recommends here for white because if we're
already looking at this, we might as well look at this from white's point of view and
fill ourselves in on what to do against this line from the white side because I also recommend
the Aleppine, and I don't remember very well.
So of course, the authors of the book, they analyze it through a different move order,
but we're lucky because they analyze it through this move order, but their recommendation
is in fact to play knight f3, so we get the same position as through this move order.
Okay, their move is in fact bishop c4, uh-huh, so they recommend bishop c4, and they say
white will hardly obtain an advantage after d4.
They call this move a mistake because of takes, takes, takes knight f6, knight c3, bishop
b4.
So they give this line, and they say white is not better here.
Wow, that's really good to know.
White is not worse either.
Here our opponent made the mistake of playing bishop g5, but apparently d4 does not yield
an advantage.
You're supposed to play bishop c4.
So most people in this position, they play knight f6, the vast majority of people play
knight f6.
And now we play, let's see what we play.
We play knight g5.
We play this like a fried liver, d5, ed5, knight d5.
So if in this position black plays knight a5, the difference between this and the fried
liver is that in the fried liver, you might know that black has the move c6.
Here black doesn't have that move.
Black has to cover with a bishop, and apparently you have this very powerful move, queen to
a4, a6, following bishop b7, bishop d7, knight d7, knight e6, exclam.
Black would end up in a very difficult position, f, e, d, e, and you win the knight back with
interest.
Castles, e, d, e, white is up two pawns, knight c6, wow, queen g4, defending the pawn from
the other side, and then you focus on bringing your pieces out with d3, rook g6, queen chills
out on h3, rook d6, and now you bring your pieces out, bishop e3, rook takes d3, check.
So black actually ends up winning both of the pawns back, but at the end of the day,
white gets a much better endgame because black has terrible pawns, and white has a great
square for the knight.
They give plus over minus here, followed by knight e4.
Black's bad bishop on e7 makes his defense in this endgame very difficult.
Yeah, also this bishop is bad.
So that's the line they give there.
If instead, after queen a4, black plays a6 immediately, then you play bishop d7, knight
d7, you play d3, so that the knight is protected, b5, queen is centralized, c4, okay, and d6,
interesting move.
White frees the d5 square for his queen.
It is also possible for him to continue d4, but whatever.
Let's follow the main recommendation, if, ah, there's queen d5 here, it's a great idea.
Checkmate, bishop rook.
So black can't defend everything at the same time.
Yeah, d6 is super strong, so the engine move here is rook b8, queen d5 anyway, queen f6,
b4, forcing the knight back, knight b6, wow, d7 check, deflecting the knight, e7, queen
back, knight back, bishop out, plus minus, obviously the king is terrible here.
So knight f6, knight g5, d5, ed, knight a5, bishop b5, and queen a4.
Now this is the move that I, I faced this online, ah, so now you're not supposed to
play this.
In the fried liver, this is the common trap.
Here black is actually better.
So you're not supposed to do this.
Instead you're supposed to play this move.
So you provoke g6, and now you drop back to f3.
Queen takes g5, is forced, if instead bishop e6, then you just take the bishop and black's
pawn structure sucks.
Bishop takes d5, attacking f7, knight d8, and now we castle.
And now you're threatening to play d4 and open up a discovery against black's queen.
So their main move is queen e7.
After queen f5, white can maintain an edge in the endgame, as well as by avoiding the
exchange of the queens and entering a middle game.
So they recommend rook e1, bishop g7, d4 with an advantage, obviously white is better here.
Black is super cramped and he's losing some pawns.
So queen e7 is their main move, rook e1 anyway, x-ring the queen, okay, bishop g7, d4 with
a big initiative, cd, cd, and black is under tremendous fire here.
If castles, I think you just play de, and here you have bishop f4 winning the bishop,
because black can't play f6.
Yeah, so that makes sense, that makes sense.
So basically, if white, black plays d5 and knight takes d5, you play queen h5 to induce
this weakness, you drop the queen back.
If queen f5 in this position, then you win with bishop takes c6 and you win the rook.
So black has to play knight d8, then you castle to threaten d4, and you put the rook on e1
basically, regardless of what black does.
Unless black doesn't move the queen, then you open up a discovery against the queen.
You see, this is how opening learning works, it's not a mysterious process, and this is
why books are so good, because you check it immediately, you memorize it, boom, that's
it, we'll never have a problem against d5 ever again.
So people, they mythologize the process of learning openings when in fact it's just about
getting your hands dirty and rolling up your sleeves and just like processing what's written
in a book or written in a chess book, of course, that's all there is to it.
So in the game, our opponent played an inferior move, d4 is wrong, because we get basically
a four knight scotch.
We basically get a four knight scotch without the c7 and c2 pawns, which shouldn't really
all that much change the evaluation of the position.
But bishop g5 is a very serious mistake.
The correct move here is in fact to play this like a regular scotch, bishop d3.
We would have castled or we would have played something like d5, pawn takes d5, and we get
sort of a classic situation.
Apparently there's a nice little check on e7 that you can throw in to basically force
the endgame, because in this position if white blocks with a bishop, then you play knight
takes d5, and this is quite unpleasant.
You're attacking a bunch of stuff here.
So queen e2, and apparently knight takes d5 is best, with something resembling, maybe
like a micron better for white here because of the slightly deficient pawn structure,
but black is fine in this position.
It's very solid.
I think white is a smidge, a smidge better, a smidge better in this line.
But we would have played this, we would have played d5.
Also black can castle here probably first, and then play d5.
I wouldn't play d6 here because then the bishop comes out and this pin is really nasty.
Usually you want to play d5 in the four knight scotch if you're black.
And here also, e takes d5.
This I would want to avoid with black because this is an IQP, and here it looks like white
is quite a bit better.
Maybe this is also a decent way to play this line, but bishop d5 is bad for many reasons.
One of them is that we can just play h6, and hopefully it made sense to you guys why bishop
h4 is bad because here g5, bishop g3, this is a very straightforward line, and white
is in trouble obviously.
We could have also played queen a5, the engine likes queen a5.
And the basic idea of queen a5 is that if white plays bishop takes f6, you don't just
meekly take back, you take on c3 twice.
And this is a very scary scenario because you're attacking the rook, so white can't
play queen e2.
White has to go king e2.
I wasn't sure how to evaluate this position.
I think I even talked about this during the game.
I just didn't know what the evaluation here was.
Apparently it's minus plus, black is much better.
Notice that black's queen drops back and defends the c7 square.
So white can deliver a check, but the king goes up.
And white can deliver another check, but the king goes down.
The king escapes the checks.
Actually no, this is wrong because of queen d6.
You're supposed to go king d8 so that this move is in a check.
So white has to waste the tempo, and now you open up the center with d5.
And if queen takes d5, you liquidate, blah, blah, blah, you take everything, and black
is up a full pawn in the ensuing endgame, so this would have offered winning chances
as well.
But I'm happy with it.
I think h6 is simpler because it gives us the bishop pair, and it gives us a huge initiative.
The engine is always good in such positions, but it's very, very hard for a human to play
something like this.
So we castle, and our opponent plays a3, which I think is a good move, bishop a5.
And I think rook c1 is a big mistake.
I think it's just too slow.
I think rook c1 is too slow because here we start accumulating a massive initiative.
And I'm not saying rook e8 is correct.
I just feel like rook c1 is a mistake.
According to the engine, the best approach here, either after b4 or before b4, you can
start with b4, and apparently this is the only move, queen to f3, offering the queen
trade.
That's how you douse the flames of the initiative.
And if black wastes a tempo declining the trade, then white can use that tempo to entrench
a knight in the center.
And now rook e8 is less effective because white develops very quickly bishop e2.
White simply gives up the e4 pawn and then castles.
Again, pawn sacrifices are super common here.
Black is in trouble because black is paralyzed and bishop d3 is threatened.
And black can't even do this because of the fork on e7.
So this is a very problematic situation.
Probably we would have taken the queen and done something like knight to d4 to get rid
of white's best knight on b5.
And black is still a little bit better here.
I would prefer black here, but obviously this is a better version than what happened in
the game.
Yeah, queen f3 for some reason is a hard move to find because it's just not intuitive to
go into an endgame like that.
But definitely rook c1 was very slow.
I understand why our opponent played it.
So now rook e8.
So we increase the pressure on e4.
According to the computer, apparently d5 immediately was very, very strong here.
I thought about this.
I didn't see a follow-up to ed.
But here apparently black is winning with the move bishop b6, threatening checkmate.
So let's say white defends.
Now it's minus.
Ah, now rook e8 check and white can't block on e2.
If white plays f3, then I think it's obvious why this is horrible for white is white will
never be able to castle.
This is awful.
And if white plays like this, black has this move, queen g5, hitting the rook on c1.
So that's another bad reason, reason that rook c1 was bad.
The rook actually can be targeted.
Queen g5 is a ridiculously hard move to understand like why it's good because it hits the rook.
If the rook goes here, then you pin the rook.
If the rook goes the other way, well black just gets a monumental initiative here.
The knight's coming to g4, and the e-file is open, and this is just a disaster for white.
You should understand why this position is winning for black without calculation.
You should look at this and say, yeah, I understand white's king is busted here.
This kind of intuition is very important, like roughly evaluate these types of positions.
Okay, so instead we played rook e8, b4, bishop b6, and apparently still, ah, now queen f3
still should have been played.
Yeah, I still think our opponent should have played this, although here there's already
queen g5 hitting the rook.
This is an inferior version.
According to the computer, f3 was the preferable move, but try playing this position, Jesus,
or try playing the position after just the simple move like d6, just opening up a diagonal
for the light-squared bishop.
Queen d6, there's queen g5, and again, black is winning because white just gets screwed
on the dark squares, absolutely screwed on the dark squares.
But rook c2 loses.
After d5, white is busted.
White is completely and utterly and totally busted because he's not close to castling,
and we're already massacring him in the center.
I would play queen d5 here with white.
I think it's the only chance.
So once again, knight d5, rook e4 is just game over because white loses f2.
Queen takes d5.
The simplest move is bishop e6.
The engine move is rook d8, hitting the queen that way.
Queen has no good squares.
It has to like retreat, slink away, and black is winning here with many different moves,
such as bishop e6.
Also the engine likes queen f4 for some reason.
Ah, it's a stop knight d5, so you take the pawn to the check.
White can't move the bishop anywhere but c4, and ah, this is the idea, oh my god.
Bishop f2, rook f2, of course, queen c1.
That's why we played queen f4, and now the bishop comes out, forcing the rook up, and
now we take this rook, and then we'll take the other one, and we'll take g2, and it's
totally winning.
Wow, queen f4, what a move.
Yeah, queen f4, but not the only move.
You can win like this too.
Here it's just that there's knight d5.
Apparently, this move is now winning.
Yeah, these positions are hard to play accurately, but you can kind of tell how overwhelming
it is when you see black's pieces as active as they are, which is why you play such moves
on intuition.
So one of the big takeaways from this game is like moves like d5, you should be able
to play without calculating too much.
Of course, our opponent played here, and now a very important move is bishop f5, and the
idea was that rook e2, we just take twice.
We're trying to force white to play f3, and if white had played f3, we would have brought
the rook in, and I think the rest I'll leave to the viewer to figure out why this is totally
overwhelming.
This is minus 8, because white can't move.
After knight c3, rook d8, castles bishop e4, there's nothing left to analyze.
Technically, b5 is another mistake white should take.
This would allow white to prolong the game, but this is still completely and totally lost.
The knight's coming into the center.
The bishop and the queen are permanently aimed at this very weak pawn, and this is just a
matter of relatively simple technique.
Of course, b5, rook d4, bc, rook d3 ended the game even faster.
The name of the book is Squeezing the Sicilian.
This is like what I refer to as the Aleppine Bible.
This is what I use for like all of my official recommendations on the white side.
It's cool.
We faced the Aleppine a few times, and I've shown you several ways that you can challenge
Aleppine players practically, because a lot of people will go d4, and I think a lot of
people will get into trouble exactly the same way that our opponent got into trouble.
Knight c6 is not an intuitive move, because it helps black get more pawns in the center.
You have to know that this is like the only way to keep your center intact, okay?
So g5, you force the bishop to give itself up for the knight.
You get the bishop pair, we castle, we play very patiently, rook e8, accumulate, accumulate,
and then bang, blast open the center based on intuition alone, and then attacking pawns.
And attacking queens, not getting fixated on attacking the king, but understanding that
there are other things that you can exploit while you're attacking, big, big thing that
people forget about.
They get fixated on, I have to checkmate, I have to checkmate.
They forget that the actual game-winning tactic could have nothing to do with the weak king.
It could be something else entirely, such as an x-ray or a pin against the queen.
We didn't win this game by mating the king.
We won this game by mating like the queen.
Okay, I think that'll be it for today.
That's two speedrun games, which is basically unheard of in a six-hour stream.
I think it's time for me to call it.
I want to thank everybody for watching and for the energy, unless there's any more energy
coming from the chat, just kidding.
Once again, wanted to put in one last shout out for the course.
I'll be talking about it over the next few days.
The course is out.
You can find it at the command exclam course.
It's a labor of love.
So far, we have sold, let me tell you how many people have bought the course, 124 people
have bought the course.
You can join that number.
We want to get to, our goal before we released the course was something like 5,000.
That's a very ambitious course, but if people like it, then hopefully we reach that number
one day, but we'll try.
We can get to 125.
That's for sure.
All right, guys.
Thank you so much for watching.
See you guys later.
Thanks for hanging out.
I'll stream tomorrow, hopefully.